[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Hartford
Connecticut is where George is hanging
out George how can we
help hey how you doing Kon Rachel um so
um I you know consider me and my wife
are right now pretty well off but
however you know with the economy in
today's stage I'm being a very frugal
person or someone call it being cheap um
my wife is kind of person where she
prefer take a big vacation every year uh
when I say big vacation we're talking
about probably like
67,000 um and I'm the kind of person you
know I can't go 10 15 years without
taking a vacation right so and I just
want to know in my financial state right
now can't should I be able to or should
I be a little loose with my um you know
my money or should I keep the way I have
been doing it sure okay quick questions
for us yeah so you said you guys are
well off what does that mean give us
your financial
picture okay so I wrote down some of the
numbers so right now we have a combined
income of
$210,000 uh mind you that's in
Connecticut and um we have a combin of
uh retirement saving that's between 401k
and Roth Roth IRA between the two of us
of
$315,000
um I also have a $10,000
529 uh educational saving account for my
children um what else how much you guys
make a year oh 210 between the I'm sorry
I did write that down I apologize so
you've been doing these uh six to $7,000
summer vacations yes or she wants to
start doing them so we did one last year
and I'm I'll be honest with you I'm
absolutely hooked right I wanted I want
to go back um but then I wake up on
reality like oh I can't do this you know
I need to keep saving my money because
you eventually we want to buy a bigger
house you know and do you guys what do
you guys owe on your current
house uh I owe
110,000 okay and how what other debt do
you have I have zero debt okay what kind
of money do you guys have saved that's
non-retirement
uh I have $60,000 in CD right now and I
have 20,000 25,000 cash in my bank right
now okay how long does it take you to
save up for the $6 to $7,000 vacation
that you said you could do without but
now you're
hooked George how long does it take you
to save up to 7,000 you're a budget guy
man you're all over it yeah how long so
if I if I want to save it if I put all
my mind at eff for two I can save up you
know in maybe three months right and
what's the benefit George of taking your
wife and the kids on the six to $7,000
vacation that by the way you're hooked
on well so the thing is right I'm I'm
you know I'm no problem taking it but
what if right there's a lot of what if
you didn't answer my question what are
the benefits of taking your wife and
kids on this six6 to $7,000 vacation
that you can easily cash flow and save
up for in a three month period what are
the
benefits happy wife happy life okay
great
uh not to mention you said you were
hooked on it George it's good it's good
for everybody now take me to the worst
case scenario that this six to$ 7,000
and I want to stay with this number
Rachel because that's the number you've
given us George give me this the the
thing that you're so worried about
happening where the 6 to 7,000 you're
spending on the vacay put you in a bad
spot well like I'm trying to say right I
I'm currently we are saving um to buy a
bigger house right uh we are trying to
actually move to a different state to
you know buy a bigger and nicer much
nicer house and um you know I want to
make sure I have what's your goal what's
see you're not answering my question
George you're like a politician on a
Sunday Morning Show so I'm Gonna Act
Like The Host so listen listen I'm
trying to get you somewhere okay so how
much are you trying to save every year
to get into the new house what's the
goal because I know you know it what is
it I want to say somewhere between $4 to
$50,000 every year all right so am I
understanding that you want to save 40
to 50,000 every year am I understanding
that you can't hit that number 40 being
the low number because you're spending
six to seven on the
vacation oh man this is not a result I
was hoping for what it means is I got
you because what I think I hear you say
is you can save the 40 to 50 a year and
cash flow the vacation am I right George
a George
go you know my wife standing next to me
good tell her what's her name what's her
name is she
listening she she is she you know Mary
Mary you're going on vacation Mary
Rachel and Kim say you are going on
vacation every
year you know I was I was hoping that
you guys are going to take my side and
be like you know you should do you know
George we actually did take your side
you can do both is what Ken's saying
yeah you get to go on vacation and also
George and here's the thing okay and I
think I could I could get a little bit
more on George's side I could like
empathize with you a little bit more if
George you're like hey here's our goal
here's this we could be in two years
earlier and she really wants this she
wants both like we're trying to really
Recon the the main the main reason you
said to Ken when he first asked you is
why he says what if something happens
what if the world go and it's like that
hasn't happened George you're living in
a fear that has not happened if that's
the reality then we will change it and
we probably won't go on the six to 7,000
trip that year because the world has
collapsed no if the world's going to
hell in a hand basket I'm going on
vacation, I tell you right now I'm going
to be on the beach when it all goes down
all right that's how I'm if the worst
case scenario happens pulling back your
lifestyle may be a reality and that's
what a lot of people find you guys have
gotten out of debt you have your fund
you make a great income you have savings
and retire like you're doing everything
right and you have the ability there is
margin there for you guys to enjoy your
life George you have to enjoy your life
Mary is Mary right there George is Mary
still there no she actually just left
went to a meeting I was gonna ask Mary
where you guys are going this
year actually we going to uh kin Mexico
last year and then I'm just absolutely
hooked um one thing I was I was want to
say is I think uh what it is is the
lifestyle I grew up with right I grew up
poor that's right that's right right in
my family I never went on vacation in
fact we barely L the state at all right
um so you know I still buy my clothes
from Goodwell if I buy clothes right and
um I'm gonna take you on a shopping trip
George you and me pal J crew it's going
to be great I know but that's a
legitimate thing George we do find that
you talk about that you wrote a book
about money styles know yourself know
your moneyy and you go back to Childhood
so much of how we're shaped our fears
our dreams all of that is because of the
emotional state or the true Financial
State of our household growing up so
it's very real that fear but it's not
the it's not reality George so you're
not you're not that little boy anymore
living in that scenario you're a grown
man who's done really well with your
family and that's the state you have to
live in create your free every dooll
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life